spécial cambodge donc est d'abord à
l'occasion de l'année de l'enfant ce
soir monsieur giscard d'estaing a
déclaré je vous propose de l'écouter
la situation des enfants cambodgiens est
inacceptable et intolérable
j'ai mentionné quelques-uns des
problèmes actuels de l'enfance certains
de ces problèmes se posent à l'échelle
mondiale je parlais des enfants du
cambodge il ya hélas d'autres zones
d'autres régions du monde dans laquelle
la situation de l'enfance est à l'heure
actuelle inacceptable intolérable et
naturellement il appartient au
gouvernement de prendre les initiatives
de prendre les attitudes comme il l'a
fait hier à propos du cambodge pour
souligner le caractère prioritaire de la
recherche de solution humanitaire
et pourtant en allemand